[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there are five statewide ballot
questions on your ballot this year these
would make changes to nevada's
constitution
today we want to explain ballot question
number one to you
in order to get on the ballot they had
to already pass through the legislature
twice
back in 2017 and 2019
ballot question one is probably the most
confusing one
it would remove the board of regents
from the state constitution
the board of regents oversees nevada's
university system
critics say this has allowed the board
of regents to operate without any
oversight
from the legislature former assemblyman
elliot anderson
wrote question one that restores
accountability transparency and
oversight
you know right now nevada spends 1.2
billion dollars on higher ed
but without any real oversight on how
that money is spent it would also
let the legislature create new rules and
laws overseeing
nevada's higher education system it's
really really
important for nevada and for our economy
that our higher ed system can be nimble
to answer
the issues that we need to deal with
question one
has some opposition from current members
of the board of regents but the argument
against the passage on the secretary of
state's website says
question one is nothing but the
legislature trying to gain more power
and control
and it would only serve to add political
pressures to a governance system that is
serving this state well
now if question one is passed it would
take effect on november
24th of this year